hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast application of combined
RNA in situ hybridization and multiplex
immunohistochemistry
to unravel tumor heterogeneity and
prostate cancer presented by analyst
Ephraim Palani Sami
PhD and Courtney Anderson PhD we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Novus biologicals a bio
technique and Novus biologicals
accelerates scientific discovery by
developing and marketing antibodies and
other unique products for the life
sciences the company is organized to
provide the biological research
community with a mechanism for
commercializing unique biological
materials Novus biologicals also focuses
on continually monitoring scientific
trends and supplying materials to serve
those trends by making these products
widely available to institutional and
commercial researchers Novus biologicals
plays an important role in furthering
biological research to learn more about
Novus biologicals please visit
www.opm.gov/life and I'll be your
moderator for today's event this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box for
the peers on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation and also
please note that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge window just click on the screen
icon located on the lower right and
finally if you have trouble seeing or
sharing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you
now I would like to introduce dr.
Anderson dr. Anderson is a senior
and R&D and advanced cell Diagnostics in
Newark California in her current role
she manages numerous projects with
collaborators from around the globe to
demonstrate new and exciting
applications of the RNA scope and base
scope technologies and their ability to
detect RNA biomarkers with single
molecule sensitivity and single-cell
resolution with morphological context
prior to joining ACD dr. Anderson
completed her postdoctoral studies in
metabolic biology at the University of
California Berkeley
she received a PhD in molecular and
developmental biology from the
University of California San Francisco
please join me in welcoming dr. Anderson
I will now turn the presentation over to
her thank you very much Judy for that
introduction and thank you all for
joining us today I will give an overview
of the RNA scope in situ hybridization
technology and show how you can combine
it with immunohistochemistry which I
will refer to in this talk as dual ish
IHC the first key feature of the RNA
scope technology is the unique probe
design so the first this is a basic
overview of the technology what we see
here is the permeabilization of the
cells the slide based assay so we have
permeabilization of the cells or tissues
on the slide
followed by hybridization of the target
probes to the RNA we also have
amplification of the signal following
probe hybridization and then
visualization of the staining with
morphological context because they have
single molecule resolution this can be
quantified by single cell expression now
this is just a brief overview of the
probe design the basic probe is designed
or shown as a double Z where the base of
the Z is a target specific binding site
that targets approximately 50 base
region and the top of the double Z is
where the preamplifier binding site is
present now a typical RNAi scope probe
consists of approximately 20 ZZ pairs
that allows us to target a thousand base
pair region so just to go in a little
bit more detail the first I want to show
here is the signal amplification as I
mentioned we have the double Z Pro which
binds to the target sequence upon
binding to the sequence a preamplifier
then binds to the top of the double Z
pair then multiple doubles uhsorry
multiple amplifiers can then bind to
each preamplifier and then each preamp
or amplifier can then bind multiple
labelled probes these labelled probes
can either be a chroma genic enzyme or
four for this signal amplification
strategy allows for visualization of
target rnas as a single dot where each
dot represents an individual RNA
molecule that can be quantified lastly
with the RNA scope assay background is
eliminated because the signal is
dependent on two Z's binding next to
each other on the target sequence if
both these do not die then the
preamplifier cannot form a stable
hybridization to the top of the Z and
the amplification tree does not get
built consequently no amplification of
nonspecific hybridization occurs
generating little to no background
signal the combination of the probe
design and the amplification system
ensures a high signal-to-noise ratio
provided that the target is expressed in
the sample and the protocol is followed
is recommended their performance of the
RNA scope assay is guaranteed because
tissue samples can be highly variable
proper sample preparation and the right
controls are essential to an RNA scope
experiment tissue samples must be
properly fixed and prepared so that
there is good quality RNA in the sample
and no background due to poor fixation a
CD provides guidelines and how tissues
should be fixed for optimal performance
of the RNA scope assay shown here on
this slide are serial sections from a
human lung cancer sample on which we
perform the manual read chromogenic
assay in this first panel we see our
negative control probe B which is a
bacterial gene that is not expressed in
animal tissues as observed in this
sample we see a no signal from the
Debbie probe in this middle panel is a
section from the same sample that was
staying with our positive control probe
for the housekeeping gene PB ID as
with this sample you want to be fairly
uniform detection with the positive
control probe indicating good quality
RNA certain tissues may express the
positive control probe at higher or
lower levels but in general you want to
see expression throughout the entire
sample with the results from these two
probes we can then have consonants in
the test data that we see here in the
right panel as an example I am showing a
section from the same lung cancer sample
probe for the immune checkpoint marker
programmed s log in one or PDL one PDL
one exhibits a wide range of expression
in tumor tissues in this particular
human lung cancer sample we observe
robust punctate dots with the PDL one
probe indicating expression of PDL one
in this tumor sample the controls show
us that there is good quality RNA
throughout the tissue sample and that
there is little to no background so we
can be confident that the localized
pattern of expression we observe for PDL
one is in fact the correct results okay
the article assay is ideal for many
applications including the detection of
any gene expression long non-coding RNAs
for which antibody detection is not
possible molecules that are challenging
to develop antibodies against such as
GPCRs and identifying the cellular
source of secreted protein the RNA is go
back they can also be used to validate
high-throughput data identify
co-localization of multiple genes and
visualize gene expression with
morphological and spatial resolution the
assay has been applied in a wide range
of research areas including neuroscience
stem cell and developmental biology
infectious diseases and cancer in
addition to drug discovery and
development in the biopharma arena okay
now I'd like to show you how you can
combine the RNA scope ish assay with IHC
to complimentary assays that when
combined can allow you to gain more
information on gene expression despite
the fact that ich and IH c target
different molecules they can be used as
complementary assays rather than
mutually exclusive athletes they can
each provide valuable information that
complement one another for example one
can identify the origin of secure
proteins by using ish to identify the
cells that produce the protein and IHC
to identify where the secreted protein
is located one can also characterize
complex tissue structures by using
IHC to identify the cell type and ich to
detect gene expression inside these
cells lastly one can dissect the
regulation of gene expression by using
ich and IH c to differentiate between
gene regulation at the transcriptional
level and at the translational or post
translational level here is an overview
comparing the two detection methods
while the RNA scoped ich esse detects
RNA using DNA oligonucleotide probes IHC
detects protein using an antibody both
assays can visualize gene expression
with morphological context at the single
cell level using either a chroma genic
or fluorescent signal however the RNA
scope assay can detect gene expression
with single molecule resolution allowing
for quantification of gene expression in
situ because of the similar work flows
between ich and IH c including sample
fixation pretreatment pro hybridization
signal detection and data analysis as
well as the unique benefits of each
assay described earlier ich and IH c are
ideal to combine into one workflow here
is an overview of the dual RNA scope ich
i HD workflow in which the RNA scope ich
esse is performed first followed by the
IH cfa first samples are pretreated
followed by hybridization of the RNA
scope probe and then amplification of
the RNA scope signal the IHC assay is
performed next starting with the
blocking step then primary and secondary
antibody incubation and lastly detection
of the signal which can be chromogenic
or fluorescent so we do have some
recommendations to ensure a success with
your dual ich ihcs a first
all dual ish IHC protocols require
optimization in general it is
recommended to combine a working RNA
scope protocol with a working IHC
protocol in addition you should work
with antibodies and a protocol that are
known and already established with your
tissue samples second it is advisable to
perform ich first followed by IHC third
it is also advisable to optimize the IHC
assay separately using the RNA scope
pretreatment reagents to ensure that
your target protein can still be
detected following RNA scope
pretreatment and lastly the dual ich IHC
assay works better for highly expressed
proteins due to protease treatment that
is used during the ich protocol now I'd
like to show you a few examples of the
dual RNA scope ich i HD assay shown here
on this slide is a non small cell lung
carcinoma spe section that was probed
for CDA a mRNA in green and CD 274 also
known as PDL one in red using this RNA
scope assay
this was then followed by IHC for CDA
protein and white on the same section
what we can see here shown at higher
magnification on the right is that the
cd8 mRNA signal in green co-localize
--is with the cd8 protein signal in
white demonstrating the co-localization
of cd8 mRNA and protein in another non
small cell lung carcinoma FFPE section
for the immune we probe for the immune
checkpoint markers I do one mRNA in
green and PDL one mRNA in red using the
RNA scope ish a say this we then
performed IHC for cd8 protein in white
on the same section the combined assays
indicate no colocalization of the three
molecules suggesting mutually exclusive
Co expression of P do one I do one and
cd8 in different cells
this image demonstrates how the dual RNA
scope ish IHC assay can provide further
understanding of immune function in the
tumor micro-environment and lastly here
are some more images depicting the mRNA
expression pattern of multiple immune
checkpoint markers by RNA scope ich
followed by IH C for the cd8 protein
from all of these images we can
appreciate infiltration of cd8 positive
cells visualized by IHC into tumor
regions that are marked by PDL one mRNA
furthermore if the combination of an
additional checkpoint or immune marker
provides insight to further characterize
the immune response involved in the
tumor micro-environment
for more information on the dual RNA
scope ich esse including protocol
recommendations please visit us on the
web or contact us at the addresses shown
here and now I'd like to turn the
presentation over to dr. paula nice ami
thank you dr. Anderson yes next we will
hear from dr. Palani Sami
dr. Palani Sami is an associate
scientist at the Henry Ford Health
System and holds an adjunct faculty
appointment with the Michigan Center for
translational pathology at the
University of Michigan his research
interests are on the discovery of
capsule cancer biomarkers and lymphomas
and solid cancers during his
postdoctoral research at the Memorial
Sloan Kettering Cancer Center dr.
Kalani's families were contributed to
the discovery of recurrence gene fusions
in follicular and diffuse large b-cell
lymphomas he was the founding director
of R&D at cancer genetics where he
introduced novel approaches to develop
diagnostic reagents targeting
chromosomal translocations in cancer dr.
Gulani sámi pioneered the application of
next-generation sequencing technology
for transcriptome sequencing and
discovered novel druggable gene fusions
in prostate cancer gastric cancer and
melanoma his current research aims to
understand the molecular basis of tumor
heterogeneity in solid cancers with
particular focus on prostate cancer and
its impact in early diagnosis response
to treatment and clinical
I will now turn the presentation over to
dr. Palani Sami
okay hello everyone I hope everyone will
hear me well thank you for the
introduction and also I would like to
thank Courtney Edison for giving an
excellent review of the technology and
its initial application so what I would
like to do is I'm going to talk about
the application of the RNA in situ
hybridization so here after I'm going to
call it RNA ish combined with the
immunohistochemistry
to study the tumor heterogeneity in
prostate cancer but I would like to
mention that the technique and the
application that I am presenting is not
limited only to prostate cancer so I
think any investigators who are
interested in using this technology as
dr. Anderson mentioned you know you have
to optimize this protocol in your
research needs before using it but I
think at the end of the presentation you
will be able to understand the power of
this RNA in situ hybridization combined
with the immunohistochemistry
to assess the expression of individual
molecular markers in the different
cancer type so here what I'm going to do
the objectives of my presentation is
pressed because of the essence of time I
may not be able to go into the details
of each method but I will briefly give
an overview of what I have done using
this technology so before that I want to
actually put a disclaimer that I'm not
actually receiving any funding or any
support from a CD bio I am just sharing
my experience in using this technology
for the last seven years in my research
and I have published extensively using
this technology so with that disclaimer
I would like to move on with my
presentation so the objective of my
presentation is to show the comparative
analysis of how powerful the RNA instead
of hybridization is comparable to immune
system
because as you all know everybody is
familiar with a belongs to chemistry but
uh but I want to in one slide I would
just to show you the power of the
comparable quality of the RNA into the
hybridization just by measuring protein
both DNA sorry um protein at the RNA
level then I will show you the single
plots combined immune of sugamice tree
and RNA in situ hybridization in the
prostate cancer model as dr. Anderson
she already showed how she can use it
but I am showing an example how I use it
on the prostate cancer then I will show
you the duplex or the multiplex approach
where we can actually combine both RNAs
and the immunity of chemistry and under
the duplex mode so that we will be able
to detect up to four markers in a single
hybridization and and I will show you
lastly an owner to slideshow how we can
how I have actually used this technology
with a combined and multi plugs are in
addition I ISE to study the tumor
heterogeneity in prostate cancer so in
this slide as you know that prostate
cancer is a well-characterized cancer
model where many recurrent molecule work
operations have been identified in this
think the subset of prostate cancer as
you can see in the outer line there are
many genes that are listed that are
undergoing here that mutations but in
the inner circle if you see it there are
many kind of genes that are listed
particularly the genes that are
undergoing translocations or in other
words gene fusions like the ets family
genes including the earth ET v 1e tv4 ET
v 5 and half one piece or the well
characterized recurrent the infusions in
prostate cancer so I'm using so given
this enormity of the large number of
markers I have selected only the ones
that are most prevalent like the earth
generation is present in about 50% of
the prostate cancer likes pink one in
ten percent and ETV one in five or ten
percent of the cases so I selected only
the major molecular markers and applied
this RNAs and combined IAC technology to
study that expression pattern in the
multifocal heterogeneous prostate cancer
so so for the purpose of this
presentation I'm I have selected only
four genes these are the H family genes
the earth ET v 1e tv4 and ET v5 and the
boxes represents the number of exons in
each gene and the black horizontal bar
shows the exact location of the probes
where we have designed the RNA in situ
hybridization probe although one may
think that you know you can actually
construct a plasmid and you can actually
make anti sense probe by enzymatic
reactions but those type of probes will
give more like nonspecific and the half
target hybridizations that will
compromise the quality of the results so
i would encourage anyone who are
interested in applying this RNA in situ
hybridization technology what with the
ACD biotic and technical staff they will
be able to help you to design a well
characterized and the well optimized
highly sensitive and specific probe so
that will give you a completely cleaned
results so here as you can see these
bars represent the specific regions
where we have actually identified the
qualified probes like for the earth
these probes are coming from the three
prime untranslated region then for the e
TB for almost the entire gene and can be
used like that and some like for the e
TV five only the last two exons where we
have a well-characterized probes so I
think it is important that we have to
work with a CD player to have this probe
design done so that we will get a good
quality the sauce so using these four
markers I will show you how we actually
apply this technology so here in this
slide I am showing an example to show
the comparability of the RNA Institute
hybridization with imagistic
okay so here I'm using the Erb Jean as a
model so because the Earth Jean is the
most commonly we arrange the Jean and
prostate cancer in about 50% of the
prostate cancer so here in this example
on the left side and I'm showing you the
tissue section that is hybridized with
herb antibody by immunohistochemistry
where you will see the specific
expression of the of the protein only in
the tumor area and the nothing in the
stromal area so what we did was we took
a consecutive section from the same
patient and performed RNA in situ
hybridisation as you can see the
different eight dots are actually
present only in the tumor areas and
nothing in the stromal area or in the
benign tissues so which tells you the
power of this technology and the
sensitivity and the specificity of the
probes that will recognize only the
tumor and the protein that is expressed
there okay so this is because I don't
have much time to show more examples but
I think this is more convincing to show
that how comparable the RNA in situ
hybridization in place of is see because
this is very useful when you have a gene
where for which we don't have a good
antibody I think the best alternative is
the RNAs to have a decision where you
can perform this on these tissues and
that - under bright field you know you
can see that in the next slide this is
again to show the specificity and the
sensitivity of these probes designed by
the ACD bio so here I'm showing an
example of the e TB 1 e TV for an e TV
five probes that is hybridized on a
tissue that is positive for only one
chain say for example in the top panel
that which is an e TV one positive case
which was hybridized with both e TB 1 e
TV 4
EDB hypo and we see specific
hybridization only with the ETB one
section and similarly in the bottom
panel you see that that sample is
positive for ET before and we find a
specific hybridization one before the he
D before but the ET be one and ETV if
appropriate not given her precession so
although these ed family genes have a
high sequence homology the specific and
design of the probe that helps to avoid
all the nonspecific hybridization
nonspecific signal to give you the high
sensitivity and specificity of this
probe so this is again important that
you know we did all these initial kind
of quality control validations before
actually adopting this technology in my
laboratory and all this data are
published in this paper patience of time
I'm not being not be able to show you
the complete validation data but anyone
who is interested and to learn more
about the sensitivity of this probe so
please bring this paper where we have
clearly demonstrated the application of
the army's appreciation for the
deduction of the f infusions in prostate
cancer so in this slide so I'm going to
show you a little more the application
of this RNA into the hybridization in
different type of tissues it is not only
on all kind of FOP tissues like the
radical prostatectomy or the large
tissues here I'm try to show that this
technology can be applied to needle
biopsy sample we have the sample
availability is a major limitation so
especially when you take biopsy you
don't have abundant material so you are
limited with one or two slides and if
you want to scream like three or four
markers in one or two slides I think you
cannot do these assays on a you know
kind of single plucks port so that is
important that we have to develop this
multiplex and it is working across
different tissue types so here as you
know that the SG infusions led to the
first-ever molecular classification of
the prostate cancer where we have the e
t b1
tv4 et me I would urge thence pink one
and the last infusions the identify
account for about fifty to sixty percent
of the prostate cancer and there are
specific drugs targeting the inclusions
have been developed although you know
this this blocks are not ready available
for primetime clinical use and I hope
eventually this will lead to the
clinical use but right now many thing
we're going to preclinical studies they
have clearly established the potential
of this drug targeting the specific
molecule so in this situation it is
important that we need to have as a very
sensitive I say where we will be able to
assess the presence of these molecular
markers in different tissues so in this
slide I'm showing you one poster
although this is busy you may not be
able to read the whole thing but this is
to emphasize this is the first clinical
trial that was performed at the
University of Michigan using the SG
infusion status to random
biopsy and the lymph node by
materials okay we are not using the
radical prostatectomy tissues or
anything else there's only the bone
medicine the lymph node biopsy so
imagine that the amount of material that
is available is very limited and
moreover the bone Mets biopsy because it
is associate coming from the bone the
tissue has to go through the
calcification and other complex process
that will compromise the quality of the
tissues so with that it will be very
difficult to perform like fish or any
other methods and also the availability
have a small team at issue that limits
our power to evaluate all these
molecular markers you know and so that's
why we developed that combine the IHC
and RNA is where so that we can screen
more than one marker in a single
experiment okay so this is to show the
application of this technology so here
in this slide I am showing is showing
you the systematic evaluation of of the
molecular markers and prostate cancer so
one example if it is identified with
cancer you can profile first with the
earth because of the higher incidence or
higher prevalence of this marker that
can be performed with the IHC because we
have a good antibody available the next
you can do speak one if the sample is
negative for Earth we can do a speak one
that also can be performed by IAC but
next if the samples are negative for
elkins pink one if you want the screen
by ET v1e TV for a TV five there is no
specific antibody available so one has
to do a the PCR or fish so there is no
way you can evaluate and the presence of
this molecular markers at the tissue
level so so given the importance of
these molecular markers and the
development of specific inhibitors and
potential application of these markers
in clinical trials and eventually for
clinical use I think it is important to
develop more robust sensitive and
specific tests for this model for
evaluating these molecular markers so
here in this slide I am showing you all
these markers like the Earth's pink one
Peter
the market since we have a good antibody
for p10 and speak one we can perform the
this is C either and a single plugs are
duplex mode but whereas the e TB 180 v4
+ e TB v since we don't have a good
antibody we have to perform only RNA yes
if you want to see the expression of
these genes at the tissue level although
we can do PCR and other methods but in
order to assess at the tissue level you
have to do RNA ish and similarly there
are other markers like this non-coding
RNA like PCH we pick at one slab on K KP
1 these are the well characterized
molecular markers and prostate cancer
these are all the non-coding RNA with
the important functions in the tumor
development so these markers are also
because they don't make proteins be this
well difficult to develop antibody so we
have to do evaluation only by RNA yes so
given the importance of these molecular
markers in prostate cancer it is
essential that we have to develop a
sensitive and the robust technology
whether we can develop very sensitive I
said so here in this slide I want to
show you the application of these RNA
instead of hybridization on tissue
microarray so here in such a large
tissue microarray this is a prostate
cancer tumor array we use the et b1 RNA
h probe where we clearly show that we
were able to recognize only about the 3
cases that are positive with the RNA is
signal whereas you don't find any
nonspecific or off-target hybridization
on any other case which clearly tells
the power of this technology and the
sensitivity of this approach which is
comparable to the Muniz to chemistry and
the next this is a tissue from
patient-derived xenograft tissue of a
metastatic prostate cancer so this tumor
is grown in a mouse where this team that
is positive for ET v1
performed by RNA in situ hybridisation
we were able to show the specific
hybridization only in the human tumor
tissue and there is no cross
hybridization with the mouse or storm or
anything like that which is such a
specific kind of hybridization barrier
one can appreciate so next I want to
since we have these molecular markers
and we have this combined ISE and the
RNA age so we want to apply this
technology to understand the tumor
heterogeneity in prostate cancer because
it is that human heterogeneity is a
major problem not only in prostate
cancer it is the well-known problem with
their other solid cancer as well it is
me it is the ex tumor heterogeneity is
the main reason that is actually very
difficult to make accurate diagnosis and
also to come up with a better prognosis
for each tumor
since the prostate cancer is a
multifocal disease with independent
tumors actually developed at different
stages of development so it's important
to understand the significance of
smaller secondary tumors and the
relationship between the extent of
molecular changes and the metastatic
potential of individual tumors we need
to understand what are the driving
molecule aberrations in each tumor force
I in a multifocal cancer all these
multifocal tumors or tending Li
identical are they different okay so
that is a fundamental question that we
want to understand by using the
well-established markers so here I'm
going to show you an example how we
recognize the inter tumor heterogeneity
in a radical prostatectomy samples here
I am showing an example this is a small
tumor fossa from a radical prospect
example the entire region is shown in
the chemo toxin your sustaining the
whole area containing tumor and by fish
initially we confirm that this tumor is
positive for heat ev1 so by using our
ETV one RNA is probe we are able to
perform this hybridization and we see
that the entire tumor area
is actually hybridizing with the itv1
current color signal but within this
tumor area we found there are two area
that are completely negative for the ETV
one still it is tumor it is cancer but
there is no specific hybridization
initially we thought that it could be
some technical artifact because of some
bubble or something like that we
repeated this experiment and we
confirmed that still this area was
negative so that prompted us out of
curiosity what I did was we hybridized
another consecutive section with the
another it's family gene that is the
earth by immunised chemistry what I
found was the area that is negative for
etv one is positive for so which clearly
demonstrate the internal tumor
heterogeneity we're under the astrology
examination although they appear as a
cancerous with the same cannibalism
grade but they carry independent driver
molecular vibrations which clearly tells
that is an intraocular heterogeneity so
this we can do both by RNAs and IHC so
initially we did this on a kind of
single plug small and two separate
slides so next I will show you this is
another example to show the tumor
heterogeneity in the second case where
we recognized that is a high-grade pin
that is positive for the
immunohistochemistry and immediately
adjacent to that there is a high Gleason
grade cancer that is positive for ETV
one so right next to that each one each
tumor fossa is actually independent and
there is no overlap in the presence of
these molecular markers these markers
are mutually exclusive in HQ much for sy
and they carry two driver molecular
operations which clearly recognizes that
each team are forces that is developing
in prostate cancer may be driven by
different molecule or aberrations so
this is a well-recognized
kind of example to show the tumor
heterogeneity at the molecular level so
now so given the importance of these
molecular markers the potential
therapeutic inhibitors and with the
combined technology of IH c and RNA ich
and also given the limitation in the
availability of the tumor materials
we want to actually develop a more
robust multiplex per se where we will be
able to scream more than one marker in a
single hybridization experiment so here
I am going to show you the dual is C and
the dual RNAs where we can do we can
screen all these four markers on a
single slide in a single iodization
method okay so here as I told you before
the e TV one and E TV for we can detect
only by RNAs and the earth and [ __ ] one
we can detect by is C so here I'm
showing you this method each 1h molecule
can be recognized with the different
colors as indicated here you can see it
on the tissues so as dr. Allison
mentioned it is important that you
perform the RNA instead of hybridization
first and then then followed by the
immunohistochemistry diversity is
important that if you do the opposite
way and you will compromise the quality
of the RNA so there is a potential that
during the antigen retrieval you may
lose the Harney
so it is better to do the RNs first and
undo the amino she is stuck amidst you
on the second day on the second day so
it is important to note that you don't
have to move an empty gender 3-1 for the
second time for the immunohistochemistry
so whatever the pretreatment there was
done for the RNAs there is more than
sufficient for doing the IHC there is no
need for secondary step for language in
the table for AAC so after after the RNA
is detections you can go with the IC IC
primary antibody interbedded
overnight or whatever the time that is
needed then go for the is a detection so
you will be able to see these signals
very clearly so next I will show you
this is another example where how we can
actually get my christy more
heterogeneity
so with this I will go to the
application of the multiplex
so here in a single tumor force I as you
can see on the left side only one
portion of the tumor is actually
positive for her there is a brown stain
and immediately adjacent to that you are
seeing that area that is
negative for Earth but when we did the
et b1 that area the other areas positive
for a TV one so as you can recognize
there is no kind of humid boundary or
anything like that in terms of Gleason
yes I don't think that is any much
difference but still you'll be able to
appreciate the the difference in the in
the presence of different molecular
markers driving the growth of these
tumors and the different levels so this
is a well-recognized tumor heterogeneity
and a radical prostatectomy samples so
as I mentioned before this technique
RNAs can be applied all in all different
type of tissues so we have what we spend
a lot of time optimizing the protocols
both for because we may not be able to
use the same conditions that is used on
the radical prostatectomy on the TMA and
needle biopsy so it is important that
each laboratory spend enough time to
optimize this protocol and different
type of tissues so here and we have a
well what the protocol if anyone is
interested please email me or contact me
I'll be happy to share the protocol or
work with you to establish this photo
for in your lab so here we clearly show
that we can actually perform our names
of the hybridization or needle biopsy on
the radical prostatectomy tissues and
also on the tissue microarray so here
there another example that we perform
the RNA in situ hybridization on a
needle biopsy sample where a tumor force
I is actually strongly positive for ET
before and the area that are not
humorous froma
you don't see any background signal or
any nonspecific hybridization so this is
a very specific hybridization and it is
important to note that we can recognize
the tumor heterogeneity that I talked
about in the radical prostatectomy
samples you will be able to recognize
this tumor heterogeneity under needle
biopsy also suppose if we have a two and
two independent tumor force I separated
by a stroma or benign tissue here in
this example I am showing you there are
two foci which are very close to each
other but that is a kind of in-between
there is a benign tissue but one tumor
fossa we see there's positive strain for
the sprink one that is blue and
immediately edges and the force is
positive for ET if you want so you can I
see
this tumor heterogeneity under needle
biopsy sample as well so this has some
very important diagnostic implications
as well so this is the last slide that I
want to show you the application of this
duplex method where you can actually
combine both dual IHC and it you will
are a nation okay so this is a tissue
microarray where we were actually
fortunate to have tumors that are
actually positive for four different
markers like that is positive we have a
rearrangement positive samples ETV one
et before and [ __ ] on positive sample
the one thing important that I want to
mention that in prostate cancer these
molecular markers will be present only
in the tumor samples there is no
endogenous or background level of
expression of any of these genes in the
benign tissue or the x-fusion negative
samples because genes
I heard golly T V 1 ret before or
expressed only after up the chromosome
translocation only when there is a gene
fusion you will see the expression of
these genes and other important point
that I would like to make is that these
markers are mutually exclusive that you
don't find like two markers present in
the same tumor force I as I told you and
showed you in the tumor heterogeneity
examples where independent tumor force I
are the one driven by different
molecular vibrations so here in this
example I clearly show that for
different tumors that are positive with
all different markers like the red color
that is positive for the top one that is
positive for et before and right next to
that that humor is positive force pink
one and the middle one that is positive
for Earth that is recognized by the
green color and at the bottom right
there is a tumor that is positive for
ATV one that is recognized by any T we
want Sigma so each one you know you can
clearly separate these markers with the
respective distinct colors and the other
thing you can visualize under a bright
field this is such a very clear example
where you can actually can
this combined dual is e and the dual RNA
is to detect up to four different
molecular markers so here because since
in prostate cancer these molecular
markers are actually expressed in a
mutually exclusive manner but it may not
be the same killed in other cancer as
well supposedly anyone is interested in
applying this technology in the
multiplex approach to to study or to
evaluate that is more than one markers
expressed in the same tumor then each
one has to develop their own assay our
suppose if these tumors are and these
markers are expressed like one is
nuclear and other one is cytoplasmic
still you will be able to use it under
even if they are expressed in their same
tissue okay they will so you want to be
careful in designing your experiments in
such a way that these markers have a
distinct pattern of expression is a
nuclear or cytoplasmic are mutually
exclusive party in that way you will be
able to actually evaluate all these
molecular markers in an easy being so
because of the limitation in the
availability of the chromosomes I think
right now we have only this four marker
evaluation at this point and we are what
continue to work to develop and even
adding more colors in this so right now
the other important point that I want to
mention is and this four colors are
saved but both combined is C and RNAs
can be performed both by manual method
and also by automated method so you
don't have to think about that the need
for having an automated instrument in
your lap even if you don't have an
automated instrument you still you will
be able to do it in a manual method so
right now in my laboratory all these
experiments are done by manual
procedures although we have and the
automated instruments we have actually
optimized the protocols to run it on the
machine
so there also you can do both dual IHC
and a dual RNAs on the automated method
as well so so you are not limited with
the availability of any instrument
or anything like that if anyone is
interested you know even without the
instrument you can do it by manual
method and if you have an instrument you
can do it in the automatic method for
the application of the automated method
please contact the ACD bio they'll be
able to give you the all the information
how to set up this this procedure and if
anyone is interested to set up this
manual procedure and I'll be happy to
share my experience and our protocol so
that they can easily adopt this method
in your laboratory I think with that I
will stop and I want to acknowledge the
people who are involved in this study my
research coordinator Shannon Connell
who's the one who performed all these
experiments is E and the RNA and
experiment and dr. Nilesh Gupta Shawn
Williams and in the challenge a cheetah
we are our pathologist at the Hindi for
the whole system who helped me in
providing the tissues and evaluating and
the tumor samples and also the staining
patterns and dr. money man and who's our
Chairman who is the leading surgeon in
the urology department who perform all
the radical prostatectomy which leads to
the kind of tissue resources for our
research and this work is supported by
funding from the Department of Defense
grant to me and also startup funding
from the Henry Ford Health System and
last I want to thank advanced the
Diagnostics for working with me had
really on a collaborative basis by
meeting with all my elephant needs in my
research so whenever a contact them they
are very kind of cordial and very
helpful and accommodating in actually
designing and kind of read and different
probes and I really appreciate their
help in my research I think that I will
stop my presentations and will be happy
to answer any questions from the
audience thank you very much thank you
both for your informative presentations
it's time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask dr. Anderson and or
dr. Poole on Asami please do so now just
click on the green two and a button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen
click on the send button will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay let's get started
our first question is for Courtney does
each dot represent one mRNA or 1zz care
sure so each dot actually represents a
single mRNA transcript can I use the RNA
scope technology for short RNA sequences
like micro RNA or is it only for longer
RNA molecules so the RNA scope
technology cannot be used to detect
micro RNAs
we can go as short as a fifty nucleotide
sequence okay this one's for you - this
dual RNA scope and I HD work better with
fluorescent labels or with colorimetric
labels they they work with both labels
so again you'd want to optimize the IHC
first but you can certainly use both
either chromogenic
or fluorescent eight different you - why
why not do the RNA ish second since it
requires protease treatment is they RNA
- degraded so in how so we have tested
the protocol and we found in our hands
that it works best to perform the RNA
scope assay first followed by the IHC so
that's what we recommend okay another
one for you are these combined assays
second on these combined assays
optimized for automated scanning and if
so which platforms were tested thank you
sure yes you can perform this automated
we have optimized it on the leica bond x
bond rx platform okay another one for
you which I H ihp should be favorable
after RNA ish process after the RNA ish
process I mean direct I HD or indirect
by HD okay so really you can use either
the only thing we just recommend that
you have a working IHC protocols first
so whatever works best for you in your
hands if the direct IHC works or the
indirect IHC as long as that is working
optimally
with the RNA scope pretreatment you can
use either one okay and all of this next
one's for you can I ask which instrument
you are using for the automated staining
right now we have the ventana' discovery
XD okay and this next one is for you too
you mentioned briefly that the RNA scope
protocol treatment preempts the
requirement for heat antigen retrieval
later on during I HC is this true for
any and all I'm sorry abs that require
antigen on one second my question just
jumped away from me there with me one
second let's see you mentioned briefly
that the RNA scope protocol treatment
preempts the requirement for seat
antigen retrieval later on during IH see
is this true for any and all I'm sorry
ABS that require antigen retrieval I
think this has to be optimized for
individual gene targets but right now
based on our experience for the
molecules that we worked up so that's
what we learned that you know we don't
have to do a second antigen to table
because initially we thought that we
have to do it when we did it that
compromises the quality of our results
that affected the intensity of the
signal and some of the expression level
was kind of low so I what we learned was
even without the second antigen
retrieval step we can get away with that
and we got kind of high quality results
at least got the genes that we are
working on so this may not be the kind
of same thing when people are working on
other teams as well it may you know need
and the gen 2 3 well ii so i think i
think that's why it is not randall and
myself we want to insist that if anyone
is adopting this technology it is
important that you have to individually
optimize this protocol both for IH c and
rnas for the gene target that they are
working on then then they can actually
combine it before combining it i would
recommend highly recommend that each
kind of gene table that has to be tested
on a single blocks more first okay thank
you for that Courtney and excellence for
you when it's done first then IHC is
there a problem with RNA scope probe
binding to the target RNA during IHC
washes no so the RNA scope protocol is
all completed first so this signal has
already been detected so then you would
proceed with the IHC so you don't have
to worry about the probe binding the
signal has already been detected for RNA
scope okay this next one is for either
of you how do you preserve the RNA
quality for ich so there is no
particular method for preserving the RNA
but I what I recommend is always make
sure that if you have a tumor in a
paraffin block
don't cut the slides abroad so cut the
slides only when you need it so it is
not recommended that you cut the slides
and keep it in the room temperature or
anything like that so I would recommend
use the slides that are cut within like
one to three months they are ideal they
give without any compromising the
quality we'll get good results so any
slides that are cut and kept in bone
temperature for more than like three
months are definitely with this after
six months I would not recommend using
those slides so if you have a tumor
block please please preserve the block
in the negative temperature control
conditions so whenever you need just go
ahead and cut the slides I would
recommend using fresh tissue sections
rather than kind of archived in a kind
of slides cut a long time ago on Capitol
dome temperatures I think it may work if
the slides are actually cut and kept in
like minus eighty or Nicole temperature
it might work but it is up to the
individuals they have tested at least a
couple of pilot kind of experiments that
is the only kind of material available I
got to run some pilot experiment to see
where there are and a still preserved
otherwise I would always recommend to
use fresh tissues within a one to three
months old okay this next one is for
both of you Nala you might want to jump
in first what is the maximum thickness
of the sections that can be done for
dual ish
right now in all our experiments we are
using the FFPE sections cut at 3 micron
thickness I don't even go for 5 microns
we always use 3 microns I'll say a CD
we've tested at 5 microns so that that's
all that we've optimized in okay okay
and the next ones Courtney how can you
quantify the our mrna signal sure so
since each mrna transfer the dots
represent a single mRNA transcript you
can count the dots so one could be done
manually a CD has an RNA scope scoring
system where score of 0 to 4 based on
number of dots per cell you also can use
a digital imaging software systems such
as halo from indica labs or image j
software platforms like that that will
actually count the number of dots in a
particular region or in a specific cell
okay let's see Courtney this one is 4 by
you does the fluorescence of fish
effectively proceed which i HD
thereafter no we haven't seen any change
in the fluorescence signal if you do ish
first followed by IHC okay here's
another one for you
that's if one can use FFPE tissue with
ish how do you optimize I guess you
absolutely can use FFP FFPE tissue with
in situ hybridization specifically the
RNA scope assay we first recommend again
following our fixation protocol for the
tissue which is 16 to 32 hours in ten
percent neutral buffered formalin and
then you would want to embed and as Nala
mentioned you want to keep your blocks
stored properly and use freshly cut
sections for the assay and then
following that we have a pretty
standardized protocol for the actual RNA
scope si que Nala this nixon's for you
are all four colors on the same sample
no
not although as I mentioned before these
markers are mutually exclusive all four
markers are not expressed on the same
tissue but it is possible because since
here I am showing only one tumor for
sight on a multifocal tumor if you
evaluate a different foresight it is
possible that you can see different
markers and different tumor for site but
in this example in the last slide that I
showed you where all the four colors
they are on four different tumors they
are not on the same tumors since you are
evaluating only one tumor and these
markers are mutually exclusive now there
are more than one market is not
expressed in a given tumors sample but
if you if we take a multifocal cancer in
a given patient each tumor for say may
express more than one marker yes okay
Courtney this one's for you have you
tried the dual if i hv using opal
polymers for detection in both assays uh
yes we actually have here we've tested a
PerkinElmer dyes and they work with up
to four plus a necklace or either of you
if you had to test the efficiency of
conditional knockout let's say specific
deletion of a single axon is it possible
to design the Z Z probes within that
single axon assuming the exon is larger
than 100 base pairs if not what would
your recommendation be I think it is
possible I remember I think a silly bio
they have already developed such probes
to detect kind of splice variance in
lung cancer I think if I remember
correctly all the met gene where there
is only one single exon deletion that is
splice variant so yes that can be
designed using I think we can detect we
can actually design probes from a single
axon I think depending upon the sequence
and other things I think I think
Courtney can add more on that yes we
actually have a new essay called base
cope where we can do get down to a short
as a 1zz pair probe that can span the
exon junction so we can detect either a
rearrangement of the
deleted Exxon and the new really newly
rearranged Exxon Junction or if you
prefer we can also design probes that do
sit within that deleted exon depending
on the sequence length our probe design
team can work with you to find the best
probe design that would work for your
experiment okay this next one is for
Nala can you detect the percentage of
cells expressing androgen receptor and
those other receptors for example in
stem cells within a single tumor yes we
have actually used the ACD bio probe
particularly for the androgen receptor
splice variant they are b7 which is
associated with the treatment and a kind
of resistance so we have optimized the
ARB seven specific probe and it is
working consistently well yes okay
Cortney next one's for you how do you
control probe specificity sure so we
have a two-step method one during the
probe design our probe design team will
screen against all known sequences to
confirm that we are truly detecting the
sequence of interest and also the double
z design requires that the twosies bind
in tandem right next to each other in
order for the preamplifier to bind and
the amplification system to or the
application signal to occur so if you
don't have both these binding you can't
get any amplified signal okay let's see
um there with me one second I think we
have another question for you here let's
see this one is for Nala or Courtney one
second can you distinguish normal splice
variants co-expression with wild-type
I'm sorry I don't know what MA is in
single cells and tissue this would be
Nala or Courtney I don't have any kind
of experience in doing such experiments
so as long as we have the probes that
are specifically
and that is able to detect the splice
variants and the wild-type and if you
can and detect them in with the two
different chromatin yes it is possible
to do it on a single cell yes yes if
this is a sequence that would be
sequences that are longer than 300 base
pairs that would be RF dope would be
applicable and you can do the
multiplexing to detect both okay let's
see we are almost out of time so have to
be our last question and Courtney this
one will be for you and bear with me
there are some this PFA or Z and
fixative will this affect the RNA
quality yes they all work fine so you
can use them any of these fixative and
the Artic signal will still be preserved
for RNA scope passing well I would like
to once again thank dr. Andersson and
dr. Palani Sami for their presentations
and answering those many questions do
you have any final comments for what I
would like to say that if anyone is
interested in adapting this technology
if they are new I know if they want
establish procedure in the lab finish
there feel free to contact me I will be
happy to share the protocol because
there is nothing proprietary from my
side I will be happy to work with any
investigators who wanted of this method
in the lab yes and from me I think
someone else I asked my email addresses
only I know you may want to provide that
I saw one question somebody is asking
for my email address so please make sure
that everybody all the contact they get
it yes sorry cut me yeah oh yeah no
problem I just want to say also if
anyone has specific questions regarding
the actual protocol or would like help
from support you can contact us at
support at a CD bio calm well thank you
both again and I also like to thank our
sponsor Novus biologicals for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CTE button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits and before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be
for on-demand viewing through September
21st 2017 you'll receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues to may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye thank you